do you notice reactions in the crowd
when you're performing
um definitely definitely notice
reactions and crap i
actually i mean you know you know how it
is when you perform it's like you feed
off the energy of the crowd
the crowd is what you know dictates
almost
um even if you have a set show it's
really the crowd response that dictates
where you go
so i'll change my set list depending on
where i
am if if somebody yells out something in
the crowd
i'm like the band's ready to go we'll do
it you know what i mean if that's where
the vibe is going
you know that's the fun part being alive
i know that's the thing i miss about it
because i
i love i'm still getting to perform i'm
lucky and getting to sing and stuff but
it is funny like you could do the same
set in 30 different cities and all 30 of
those shows are different because
you really do feed off of the energy of
the crowd and if they're like
crazy that night then your show's more
crazy or if they're more subdued then
you're more subdued
you totally do feed off of them but so
in these times like what's
what's the one song that kind of picks
you up no matter how down you feel
because i feel like this has been a
really hard few months oh my gosh
what song picks me up and i've been i've
been playing some
some kind of down songs too oh you're a
bad girl
like if you're in a bad mood or like
you're sad you listen to sad stuff
weird like i i discovered this song by
prince called the breakdown
and i guess i needed to break down at
that moment
and it helped me to break down like
because i'm i'm like being so strong
trying to like push through yeah and i
was like i just need to like
fall apart for a minute you know what i
mean but i love prince anyway because
but right after that i play like you
know pop life or
you know something like and it'll bring
me right back um
but i listen to house music i listen to
a lot of house music
so i'm always like dancing i'm always
every time i'm cleaning up at the end of
the night or
during the day or you know i
throw on some house music and it brings
me right back to where i need to be
you know or some music right you know
for that matter
yeah no okay i'm gonna tell you i'm
telling i'm literally john legend's
street team at this point with his new
album
but you have to listen to bigger love
his new album is so good so if you need
something to be listening to while
you're cleaning your house like you just
said
you're welcome in advance yes you gotta
check it out i'm just saying
do yourself a solid enough by the way
you love what it cut out you're on the
shelf
i love you i love you man you just like
your energy and just your choices in in
the people that you choose and
like the the love that you show them uh
i think it's just incredible your energy
is just unbelievable and you somebody
who can blow
everybody away with your voice so for
for people to hear that from you man i
know it's just like
i know it means the world to them um
i just can't believe that you one know
me or like
see me on tv like i'm freaking out and
i'm going to keep it cool i'm going to
keep it chill
that was the best part of my day so
thank you um
so when i'm when i'm feeling down um i i
write what do you do like i've been
writing a ton for my next record because
my personal life is like
what right now so what it what do you do
when you're down
other than listen to breakdown by prince
[Laughter]
well luckily prince got a lot of records
that you know really
bring you up out of there yeah because
you can get sexy
you know you know
he doesn't leave you there yeah exactly
you know he'll bring you right back
um dave chappelle i've been watching a
lot of dave chappelle reruns
and i'm sorry it's it's
they are so wrong and so right at the
same time yes
and i i've been even catching my own
show living single i've been watching
living single reruns
i love that show
and i'm like like i'll just turn on the
tv and it's on and i'm i'm i'm watching
living single
um i've been watching
the 90-day fiancee all kind of
my friends are obsessed with that who
would do
that would you have done that
i know yo i don't know how i got i don't
know how i got pulled into
it but i think it's funny watching
people watch tv
you know celebrity watch you know people
watching
tv is funny because
you know yeah no i love you i i know so
many people
that are hooked to 90 day fiance i've
never seen it but i keep thinking
what like they don't know these people
and they're just like like
i don't know if i've ever been that
lonely like like i don't know if i've
ever been
like and i've been lonely before like
i'm like but i don't know if i'd just
risk it i'm just like yeah you might
work
like i don't know that seems like a
single isn't that bad right like
i'm gonna come out with that show single
ain't that bad we're gonna show
people single lives just living their
best lives
because people always hate on it
so are you excited to do action though
like this is because your dad used to be
a cop
did he give you any advice of this role
or anything like that or is he jealous
because you get to
play this like on tv no actually my dad
is go d yeah it didn't good dana do it
david
first of all my father gave you know he
gave my brother and i guns when we were
like five
and my mother was like what she's
she instantly and got rid of him
so yeah
[Laughter]
this was like normal he was like okay
you're going to get this
38 you're going to get this german move
here and this i'm going to teach you how
to shoot you know so he did
and teach us how to respect guns and
just like normal so because he
it was kind of normal around our house
but my mother never liked
the gun and stuff but we were all into
it we love
karate you know every time my father
came home from work it was like okay
attack daddy you know
like you know and he was just like
and everything because
and so this is like kind of normal like
fun stuff that we got to gr
do growing up and now i get to uh
my father's always been with me on like
almost every movie that i do he
he was initially he was security for me
like like watching my back
um and then he became just the eyes you
know i had a
my other uh friend of mine who i grew up
my next door neighbor
he became my bodyguard and my father was
also there too because my father's eyes
are just he's just sharp as an eagle
so he would make sure things were safe
he was you know like when i did this
movie uh last holiday
i had to sit on a ledge of this like
fifth you know five-story building
nope and so he sure they put this this
kind of crane thing under me
so if i fell i would only fall like 10
feet
you know what i mean not uh only 10 feet
i'm out for that too
so you know pops is always you know he
daddio has always been around
and you know so he's excited about this
he's
he's excited about me doing it and and
i'm trying to get i'm trying to steal
some of his ideas because my father's so
cool
i just want to use some of his skills in
in this because i think it'll make me a
cool character
oh my gosh i love your relationship
that's so awesome just to hear like that
girl dad relationship that's really
really beautiful
you